[Music]  hey man  you're up here  huh  mud  [Music]  together  hey look out the window  welcome to my party guys  [Music]  thank you so much for having us this is  my chance to reconnect with the girls  this little bump right here that's you I  still miss her every day  Step At Me  what's that there's something Crossing  up ahead  keep the girls in the car stay in the  car okay just stay in the car yeah okay  what's he saying devil  in anything like this  multiple attacks without eating its prey  lives don't do that at least no lion  I've ever seen  [Music]  go back to the calls  breathe slow down  we're in his territory now  foreign  it's the law of the jungle  it's only law that matters  you shouldn't be out here  I've got to get my girls out of here  I need you to trust me right now  I'm coming back  don't you move okay  huh  we're gonna go  [Music]